mais tu sais qu'ils retournent vegas ça
serait pas monsieur grands voiliers
trajet fait retour 14 heures je crois
14h entre trois avions c'est bizarre las
vegas los angeles los angeles paris on
repasse au dessus de vegas ok et ensuite
le fait de revenir ici à la maison ça se
passe bien c'est vous ça fait du bien
génial si j'ai vu plein de choses
extraordinaires et aujourd'hui je vous
parlais du nom d'un produit que j'ai
trouvé vraiment intéressant c'est asus a
jusqu'à présenter un nouveau chrome vous
convaincu plein de choses moi ce que
j'ai regardé son chromebook je trouvais
vraiment intéressant je vous ai encore
jamais parlé de chromebooks vite sa
pointe l'occasion dans des ennuis ont
été voir ce produit directement vegas
vous parlez de nouveaux chromebook un
chromebook en plus ce qui est
intéressant qui fait un grand écart à
360° vous allez voir vous allez tout
comprendre c'est vachement bien
bergessio sera donnée les gars on se
replonge un peu dans l'univers de las
vegas du nevada vous allez voir c'est
vraiment cool et ça fait du bien
[Musique]
aujourd'hui sur le stand d'asus
directement au cs ici planqué dans un
coin pour regarder un nouveau produit ça
est ce que vous connaissez
ça c'est un nouveau chromebook signe
asus
[Musique]
en kz
son petit nom c est le chromebook flip
c'est 436 je sais pas si vous êtes
coutumier si vous connaissez les
chromebook et si vous savez à peu ça
c'est en fait un chromebook celui là en
tout cas signé asus garder c'est marqué
dessus
noir sur blanc c'est comme un pc sauf
que c'est pas un pc c'est un pc sans
windows ça pc qui tourne avec chrome os
vous avez donc un os 100% google qui est
dédié aux services google donc l'intérêt
pour vous connecter en ligne utilisé
facilement tous vos services google
votre compte google votre gmail via
youtube tout ce que vous voulez et pas
la pression je vais pas venir
télécharger dans le pays sans ça c'est
vraiment la donne de ce produit c'est
l'idée du chromebook en tout cas alors
le chromebook ça développe de plus en
plus ça type de produit qui a amené à se
développer davantage dans les années à
venir et il ya des marques comme asus
qui vous propose des solutions
intéressantes comme celui là comme ce
nouveau projet lors ce produit est cool
pour plusieurs raisons vous avez votre
chromebook 1 et toutes vos applications
vous appuyez tac vous venez à garder la
balle et vous avez tous là vous venez
vous montez vous avez toutes vos
différentes applications qui sont ici
posée pour retrouver google chine google
docs
bien évidemment le plextor gmail
compagnie youtube tous les services
google vous allez pouvoir voir vos
google photos en fait tout ce que vous
voulez donc vous avez tous ici ça déjà
c'est vachement bien mais le point qui
en plus vraiment hyper intéressant que
ce produit tout cas moi ce que j'aime
beaucoup c'est le côté philippe alors le
courtier flic c'est ça ou parler votre
en bouc et vous allez venir retourner
l'écran et vous allez pouvoir utiliser
de différentes manières une fois fermée
comme ça dans ce sens là vous l'utiliser
comme une tablette
enfin une énorme tablettes parce que
franchement déjà ses titres à grand et
c'est vachement bien
donc vous l'utiliser comme une grande
table est comme ça à l'horizontale ou
alors comme ça à la verticale ça va
s'adapter en fonction de vos besoins en
fonction de vos usages
lorsque vous allez le prendre sans vous
dépouiller sur vos genoux des pouvoirs
venir travailler et être productives ou
divertir ou carrément vallée des séries
ça je trouve ça vraiment bien vous
mettez un petit ne fixons un petit
youtube pour regarder les vidéos de
monsieur rousset hypra cool ou alors
vous allez mettre comme sa forme à un
peu cheval et vous allez le poser sur
une table et de la même manière vous
allez pouvoir soit travaillée dessiner
la même manière même avec un stylet vous
expliquera dans quelques instants
ou alors regarder du contenu multimédia
donc l'aider vachement bien mais il
lorsque vous leur tournée que vous le
basculer comme ça bien vous l'utiliser
comme n'importe quel ordinateur est
standard avec votre clavier
si c'est du quartile parce qu'on est aux
us nous vous l'aurez en azerty son
problème votre pavé tactile ici et là
vous avez une machine pour se tirer d'un
côté un peu plus standard poor qu'asus a
bien bossé là dessus parce que on
apprenait quatre belles finitions en
production
assez léger en terme de connectique on
n'est pas trop mal on à de l'usb t-il
sait on à une prise jack
on va voir un bouton pour venir l'allumé
pour l'éteindre extrêmement facilement
on va se retrouver avec un petit bouton
de volume également sur le côté vous
avez quatre haut parleurs un à gauche à
droite
vous les avez également sur le dessus
avec un sont signés arman cardon vous
allez retrouver aussi un lecteur de
cartes microsd pour tous ceux qui
veulent brancher une carte micro sd
pouvez le faire vous avez de l'usbc de
chaque côté pour venir recharger pour
venir brancher un disque dur et enfin
tout ça vraiment vraiment cool c'est un
produit qui vient d'être annoncé la
hausse est ouest exit dans différentes
configurations
je sais pas quelle configuration va
arriver sur le marché français pour
l'instant je peux pas vous le dire on
sait qu'il y aura du x3 il 5 il s'est
cassé une version avec un intel core i7
en termes de performances en est pas mal
on va pouvoir monter jusqu'à 16 giga de
ram
lp ddr3 et jusqu'à 512 jia de stockage
en ssd autant dire que là dessus en
terme de performance pour la rotonde sur
un chromebook est quelque chose qui est
assez light on est vraiment bien d'avoir
une chine qui est assez performante
alors je vous dis aujourd'hui je
m'absente lui ment pas vous dire quelle
configuration on va être disponible en
france
on le verra ça rester connecté on en
reparlera probablement dans les temps à
venir sinon vous allez sur le site de
asus il vous aurez toutes les
informations sur ce produit
pareil en termes de tarifs j'ai pas
d'infos on m'annonce effectivement un
tarif dans la configuration la plus
élevée c'est à dire intel core i7 cia de
ram 512 de ssd on pourra trois ans
autour des 700 800 euros ça peut
paraître effectivement un peu élevé pour
un chromebook mais par contre sachez
quand même que derrière vous avez ce
qu'il faut en terme de performance alors
avoir bien évidemment ce qui pourrait
arriver si ça arrive sans intel core i3
i5
ça peut aussi être suffisant par rapport
à différents usages en tout cas moi je
trouve vraiment sympa c'est un produit
qui est fait en magnésium 1,1 kg sarah
qui se tient bien compact bonne prise en
main
on a vraiment la sensation plus d'avoir
un un petit pc dans les mains pouvoir
conduit sur un chromebook on a vraiment
de belles finitions fait par asus là
dessus donc je trouve ça assez rassurant
et est même le côté philippe parce que
c'est toujours la même chose quand on
dit que c'est un produit qui va être
restituée on peut toujours se poser la
question du mécanisme est ce que ça
d'alès qui va durer dans le temps
quelle est la qualité du produit et là
je suis franchement assez satisfait pour
sa bien la charnière sans vraiment très
cali alors après asus tu sais pas une
botte qui vient d'arriver en termes de
maîtrise de matériel sont vraiment forts
le produit je trouve extrêmement
séduisant à noter que sur le clavier
vous avez aussi un petit lecteur
d'empreintes digitales
déverrouillez extrêmement facilement
votre doigt ça fonctionne ça marche
qu'est ce que vous allez pouvoir venir
en faire l'idée c'est effectivement de
vous connecter partout très facilement
alors là dessus vous n'avez pas venir
pouvoir insérer de cartes sim non donc
il vous faudra forcément soit une
connexion wifi sens du partage de
connexion avec vos smartphones donc il
faut effectivement une couverture
internet
profitez de tous la suite google c'est
vraiment l'intérêt et l'adn du
chromebook a donc qu'est-ce que vous
allez pouvoir en faire là je dirais sans
de la petite productivité sur le fait de
pouvoir travailler sur du document
partagé par exemple sur google docs sur
google chiite et puis bien évidemment
toutes les différentes applications 2d
pouvoir installé depuis le plextor comme
on l'est sur des apps comme un style
dépit de plextor on n'a pas à se poser
la question des virus dont vous êtes
quand même relativement tranquille pas
d'antivirus à venir la taille là dessus
donc une machine que je trouve rassurant
rassurante pour l'utilisateur qui a pas
envie de s'embêter
ça peut aussi être assurant je sais pas
moi pour mes parents par exemple
j'imagine très bien ma mère vida bossé
là dessus sans aucun problème et pas
venir se poser la question de mettre à
jour son antivirus ou est-ce que j'ai
antivirus ou qu'est ce qui peut lui
arriver est ce cas-là firewall c'est
assez rassurant pour cette typologie de
personnes donc pour le particulier déjà
c'est vachement bien
lorsque vous utilisez tous les services
google alors bien évidemment il vous
faut votre compte gmail il faut que
j'utilise les produits google
si globalement il n'y a pas d'intérêt
mais si comme moi vous l'étude et ça
fonctionne ça peut fonctionner également
pour le professionnel imagine
l'entreprise qui va donner ce chromebook
un commercial dire ok tu peux faire tout
à saisie de données tu vas avoir faire
tout en reporting avec extrêmement
facilement à une machine qui est bien
qui est polyvalente donc je trouve que
c'est bien on va donc ces deux usages
particuliers professionnels et même des
étudiants alors peut-être pas sur la
config la plus élevée parce que 800
euros d'un chromebook c'était parce
qu'ils vont venir mettre dessus bien ce
que vous voulez faire de la saisie de
texte lorsque vous êtes en cours prise
de notes et venir travailler dessus sur
du collaboratif
sauf que c'est franchement pas mal je
vous parle effectivement de l'écran on a
un écran qui complètement tactile ça me
paraît normal avec ce produit là mais il
est compatible avec la norme musique
vous pouvez donc venir utiliser un
stylet s'ils voulaient faire de la prise
de notes du dessin de la photographie
pourquoi pas voilà un peu pour se
produire en plein d'autres choses qui
ont été annoncés quant à présenter par
asus une gamme qui renouvelait ya un
truc intéressant si c'est un pc pour les
gamer qui ne ressemble pas à un pc pour
gamers est derrière vous avez plein de
lait je trouve ça vraiment marrant parce
que ça va revenir
le personnaliser même si vous achetez ce
produit et vous l'utilisez pas pour de
guémy bien vous allez pouvoir venir
avoir un côté un peu des couacs août et
personnalisé avec une machine
extrêmement performante ça je trouve ça
assez marrant taux plein de nouveautés
pour asus sur le cs vous invite bien
évidemment aujourd'hui à rester
connectés à vous abonner parce qu'on
reparlera d'asus on reparlera de pro
asus ont effectivement parler duran
cohen de il n'ya pas longtemps on
parlera dure entre une prostate et plus
tard plus tard quand il sera annoncée
pour l'instant on n'y est pas encore en
tout cas ici on fait un gros focus pc en
gros focus chromebook sur celui là avec
cette thèse du scramble le nom ici j'ai
la petite fiche avec c'était juste
chromebook flip c'est 436 que je trouve
vraiment cool c'est comment vous
utilisez beaucoup google ça je trouve
que c'est vraiment bien c'est un beau
produit il a été annoncé il n'est pas
encore disponible la vitalité un petit
tour sur le site d'asus pour tout savoir
en tout cas ça pour moi c'est un produit
que je trouve cool il me ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire comment
vous trouvez
est-ce que vous utilisez un chromebook
est est ce que vous pourriez utiliser un
chromebook est ce que vous pourriez
laisser soit votre mac soit votre pc
windows pour aller directement sur un
chromebook utiliser tous les services
google est ce que ça vous intéresse
est ce que vous voyez l'intérêt est est
ce que vous dites est ce que c'est cool
est ce que pour vous le fait de devoir
être connecté tout le temps internet
pour l'utiliser c'est vraiment là
viennent de ce produit est ce que pour
vous c'est un bénéfice ou est ce que
pour vous ça peut être compliqué tu pas
ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire quant à nous on reste
connectés parce qu'on va continuer à
parler tech a plein de choses à raconter
yeux pleins de nouveautés sur le cms pc
smartphones il ya plein de trucs un peu
tous vraiment cool dont je vous invite à
faire une chose cela vous voulez si ce
n'est pas déjà fait vous embrasse devant
débuter demain on continue à parler tech
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]